bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france ce qu'il est
question là dans ces tensions entre la
turquie et la grèce uniquement dangereux
énergétique
vous savez les relations entre la grèce
et la turquie sont traditionnellement
assez tendue c'est une histoire ancienne
et qui s'est traduite d'ailleurs par la
division que connaît actuellement cipr
puisque après tout dans le nord de l'île
de chypre ia régime qui résulte une
invasion militaire turc en mai en 1960
et en dehors 1914 en effet et qui s'est
traduite ensuite par une déclaration
unilatérale d'indépendance de ce nord de
l'île de si l'indépendance reconnu
uniquement par par la turquie donc il
n'est pas reconnue internationalement et
on va voir des tensions puisque toute la
zone de la méditerranée orientale et
probablement riche en hydrocarbures en
gaz surtout d'ailleurs
par conséquent le le partage de ces eaux
qui peut se faire en fonction des règles
du droit de la mer ou des lignes
d'équidistance ou du plateau continental
va provoquer des conflits alors
actuellement en effet on assiste à un
conflit qui grandit entre la turquie et
et la grèce puisque la turquie a envoyé
un navire pour faire de l'exploration
sismique comme on dit c'est à dire faire
exploser des charges au fond de la mer
pour voir en fonction de la résonance
s'il y a des poches de gaz des poches
hydrocarbures et ce bateau de recherche
sismique est accompagné de plusieurs
frégates militaires
on a parlé de cette frégate militaire ce
qui en effet dépasse un peu la
protection est normal que l'on peut
accorder à pato de recherche 18 par
ailleurs les grecs disent que ce bateau
et sur leur plateau continental
je n'ai pas que par conséquent il n'a
rien à y faire alors voilà on en est là
aujourd'hui et de part et d'autre on dit
que on ne cédera absolument rien sur les
principes du côté grec au on affirme
qu'il ya une atteinte à l'intégrité
finalement de leurs zones maritimes
du point de vue du droit maritime
international
la turquie est ce qu'elle a toute la
légitimité pour justement ce rouvert ses
hydrocarbures en méditerranée orientale
évidemment il peut le faire dans les
hôtels à la maîtrise et c'est justement
le problème c'est que là où elle
entreprit de faire des recherches
sismiques dans les prochains jours eh
bien les grecs disent qu'il s'agit d'eau
qui sont au dessus du plateau
continental grecque et par conséquent
que la turquie n'a rien à y faire
ce sera ensuite la même chose
probablement lorsque la turquie fera des
recherches au large de la partie nord de
l'île de chypre
et puis comme on l'a dit là la nature
qui a passé à un accord de délimitation
des zones avec le régime libyen de
tripoli avec le gouvernement tripoli qui
est avantageux pour la turquie
par conséquent il ya un grand jeu qui
est en train de se développer entre
plusieurs pays parce que bien entendu
l'egypte est aussi partie prenante à ce
jeu dans la méditerranée orientale mais
aussi le liban mais aussi israël mais
aussi chypre et par conséquent nous
sommes au début d'une dune un grand jeu
autour de ces hydrocarbures
justement le la grèce qui demande un
sommet d'urgence à l'union européenne
est ce que bruxelles va soutenir la
grèce dans ces dossiers alors ce mais
c'est un bien grand mot mais en effet le
ministre grec a demandé une réunion du
conseil des ministres des affaires
étrangères donc ce ne sont pas les chefs
d'état de gouvernement mais les
ministres des affaires étrangères je
crois comprendre que pour une autre
raison qui est les élections et
l'appréciation sur les élections au
bélarus
ce conseil des mises affaires étrangères
pourraient se réunir après demain
vendredi
dans cette hypothèse et il est certain
que le ministre grec prendra
l'initiative de soulever à nouveau la
question de la du comportement des turcs
dans les eaux grecques et votre question
que peut faire l'union européenne mais
l'union européenne est en négociation
permanente avec la turquie
les relations sont difficiles le haut
représentant pour la les affaires
étrangères et la sécurité monsieur
joseph bourrel était à ankara au début
du mois de juillet et on est revenues
d'ailleurs avec des sentiments un peu
mitigés avec l'impression que la turquie
n'avait pas l'intention de négocier sur
quoi que ce soit elle lui a fait
reproche du fait que les accords entre
la turquie et l'union européenne n'était
pas totalement appliquée du fait que les
visas pour les turcs étaient accordés
avec difficulté mes enfants après tout
en étant en période d'urgence sanitaire
on peut comprendre que les visas ne
soient pas accordées de façon très
libérale et il a aussi reproché le fait
qu'on négocie pas une modernisation de
l'accord d'une autre manière qui existe
déjà depuis de nombreuses années entre
la turquie et l'union européenne alors
et puis il ya évidemment les trois
millions et demi de réfugiés syriens qui
sont sur le territoire turc est
périodiquement monsieur norman laisse
planer la menace dans le fond dans
l'essai repartir certains vers la grèce
c'est vers l'union européenne
donc il ya beaucoup de sujets dont
peuvent discuter
l'union européenne et la turquie et est
bien un nouveau sujet vient de s'y
ajouter car en effet il est probable que
le conseil prendra en compte l'attitude
de la grèce vendredi prochain et que
sous une forme ou sous une autre
peut-être une résolution politique
il apportera son soutien aux grecs en
demandant que des conversations et lieu
qu'une solution pacifique soit trouvée
pour l'année des mutations des jo merci
à vous que la blanche maison je rappelle
que vous êtes ancien ambassadeur de
france